wie soll's weihnachten eigentlich laufen
da wollen wir nicht bis auf den letzten
drücker warten um das essen irgendwann
zu bestellen sondern das wollen wir
jetzt planen und wie plant eine
großfamilie weihnachten gucken wir mal
zu den haases nach marzahn hellersdorf
peter hell ist dort im wohnzimmer bei
den haases sieben kinder dort wie wird
dort weihnachten gefeiert und vor allen
dingen lässt man sich da von der
regierung sagen wie man weihnachten
feiert peter kai das ist genau die große
frage hierbei den haases die wirklich
ein turbulentes jahr hinter sich haben
ich möchte die familie einfach noch mal
vorstellen für die die ist sie noch
nicht kennen familie hase wohnt wie du
sagt es in berlin marzahn hellersdorf da
ist auf der einen seite vater rené 54
jahre gebäudereiniger in teilzeit die
kleine zellen lionni ahorn connor und
danny alleinerziehend die mutter
getrennt und diese familie hat im
prinzip alles durchgemacht in diesem
jahr was man eigentlich durch machen
kann
es ist homeschooling hat stattgefunden
die n die älteste tochter die 16 jährige
tochter ist quasi als lehrerin
eingesprungen der vater hat alleine den
haushalt gemacht die kinder werden jetzt
getrennt in den unterricht reingebracht
also hier ist wirklich ein regelrechtes
tobago und vor allen dingen was hier bei
familie hase wichtig ist oder was sehr
gravierend ist ist dass jede
entscheidung der bundesregierung diese
familie hautnah miterlebt das heißt jede
kleinste veränderung ist wie ein
seismograph ihr in dem haushalt weil
jeder natürlich ein unterschiedliches
leben hat ein jeder steht
unterschiedlich auf die berufe conny zum
beispiel hat ihren beruf des friseurs
verloren aufgrund corona also das sind
alles sachen und jetzt steht weihnachten
vor der tür und weihnachten ist ein fest
der familie ein fest der liebe und auch
bei den haasis hat man sich hier sehr
darauf gefreut und ich möchte mal die
frage weiter geben wie hat sie sich
vorbereiten oder was erwartet sie
eigentlich von der regierung vor allen
dingen wenn starke einschränkung
stattfinden ich möchte vater rené haase
von der hase was erwarten sie sich von
weiner
bzw wie reagieren sie jetzt darauf falls
es zu einschränkungen kommt ja
schlimmste einschränkungen wäre halt
wenn weihnachten in beschränktem maße
erlaubt wäre
aufgrund der tatsache dass wir also dass
ich auch ältere kinder mit eigenem
haushalt habe wäre dies das erste mal
seit vielen jahren dass wir nicht
gemeinsam alle heiligabend verbringen
können für mich ja schließlich da nicht
wirklich so der sinn weil wenn
heiligabend zwei familien hier bei mir
sind und und am ersten feiertag zwei
anderen familien und am zweiten feiertag
noch mal zwei familien dann ist für mich
darin nicht wirklich der sinn gegeben
als wenn wir alle an einem tag zusammen
sitzen und wie bei uns seit jahren
tradition ist würde unsere familie schon
ziemlich stark belasten weil wir sind
halt einfach gewohnt als riesen familie
immer zusammen zu feiern den heiligen
abend und das wäre eigentlich das
schlimmste an silvester habe ich dann
geburtstag und auch da wir die
einschränkung dann extrem 31.12 wenig
aldi- umsätze mit den kleinen es ist
nicht dasselbe als wenn man in familie
feiern kann
was kritisieren sie jetzt speziell an
der regierung was sagen sie müsste mehr
für die familien gemacht werden ist das
überhaupt noch nachzuvollziehen was sich
da allwöchentliche abspielt also viele
sachen sind überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehbar
alle vorsicht in allen ehren
ich kann das auch alles verstehen wie
das man nicht sofort eine lösung für
alles hat aber es wären meiner ansicht
nach viel zu schnell irgendwelche
entscheidungen in den raum geworfen
die für otto normalverbraucher einfach
nicht nachvollziehbar sind
wie es war sagte ich verstehe nicht
warum ich nicht mit meiner familie
zusammen feiern kann
typische beispiel drei handwerker sind
die ganzen tag zusammen auf der
baustelle und nach feierabend dürfen die
drei nicht für nachhilfestunden bier
zusammen trinken ist nicht
nachvollziehbar wenn das keiner
sicherheitsvorkehrung gib mal die frage
weiter anleihen
was wünscht ihr euch als kinder am
meisten zu weihnachten oder wie würdet
ihr zum beispiel bei einschränkungen
reagieren was haben wir es ja meistens
weihnachten das wirklich das fest der
familie und da sollte die familie auch
zusammenbleiben und würde schon gerne
sehr dürfen inventar einschränkungen
kommen würden weil die sackgasse zu
jedes jahr so zusammen gefeiert und wäre
sehr traurig drüber und du jane was für
ein studio am meisten ist alle familien
zusammen feiern dürfen
und glaubst du das passiert zu zehn
prozent ist passiert und genau was sagt
ihr dazu wie wollt ihr weihnachten jetzt
holen konnte denn endlich mit allen
familienmitgliedern feiern dürfte also
ich finde es da dann blöd dass man nicht
mit der ganzen familie fällen kann weil
das ist einfach blöd da sollte man
zusammen feiern und nicht weiß erklären
nicht getrennt feiern
also man hört mein familie hase und das
geht wahrscheinlich auch tausend anderen
familien so ist die angst natürlich sehr
groß dass jetzt einschränkungen von der
bundesregierung kommen dass man bei dem
fest der liebe eben nicht zusammen sein
kann und hier wartet man natürlich sehr
gespannt auf den mittwoch auf dem tag
der entscheidung wie die regierung jetzt
plant für deutschland das familienfest
das weihnachtsfest gestalten zu können
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren